[موسيقى]
يقول الناس ، مثلما نفعل
ذلك ، لأن اللون الأسود يمكن أن يكون باليه ، لذا
فهذا بديل لا علاقة له به ،
وسأخبرك أن كل فتاة في
هذا الاستوديو مدربة بشكل كلاسيكي ،
والجميع لا يمارسون الباليه وكل شيء
else
[موسيقى]
اسمي هو ويلسون المسكين وأنا
تلة راقصة.
اسمي
Homer Hansbrough وأنا مؤسس
الورك الساق ومؤسس ومدير
مركز شيكاغو للرقص متعدد الثقافات
أعتقد أن بعض الناس يصابون بالجنون عندما نرى
طالبًا مسرحية ، إنها ليست
باليه الكلاسيكي التقليدي نحن ندمر الباليه
جيدًا ، لا  إنها ليست لعبة باليه ، إنها
الطريقة التي نمكن بها أطفالنا هي الطريقة التي
نمكن بها ساق الورك في العالم بحيث تكون
متحررة للغاية ومنفتحة هناك ثقافة مختلفة
هنا ، فإن حركات الأرض هي
شاحنة رفع الورك التي تلتف داخل وخارج مسار
التمشي على سطح القمر فيفيان
و  ريكي عليك  لديك وضع معين
عندما تقوم بالرقص ،
عادةً ما تكون هنا على الإطلاق مثل وضعية الشكل المستقيم ،
كل أحذية بوانت
مصممة للعب الباليه
مختلفة وتضرب اللعب يمكنك كسرها
بحيث يمكنك فقط تحريك جذعك
أكثر يمكنك الارتداد معها  أعلم أنه
يمكنك الاستمتاع بها ، لقد نشأت وأنا أفكر في
أنني لا أستطيع ممارسة الباليه بسبب
لون بشرتي الذي كان استوديو قديمًا
لأنني كنت أفريقيًا أمريكيًا كنت
غالبًا ما يتم تجاهله حتى أتيت إلى مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
عندما تعلمت ذلك حقًا  كان هناك
شيء ما أنا ممتن لـ Mission a
homeroom لأنه أظهر لي أنني أستطيع أن
أفعل أي شيء أحب أن أرقص الورك المضاء ،
فهو يمنحك نوعًا من
الثقة فقط ولا أحب أن تكون على
طبيعتك فقط هذا هو  نوع الرقص الذي
لا يميز
لدينا إيقاع ويمكنك أن تتأرجح في
النقطة التي حصلت عليها